years of the coronavirus mean the stock
market could be headed for its worst
week since the 2008 financial crisis the
Dow Jones Industrials NASDAQ and S&P 500
all fell more than four percent
yesterday it was the dow's worst one-day
point drop in history in the past week
the Dow lost an entire years worth of
gains closing below where it was at this
time last year CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger joins us Jill good
morning good morning is this a temporary
reaction to this that could it rebound
quickly if this calms down or this is a
long-term thing well we don't know yet
it's certainly temporary as we know it
right now here's what's really happens
fascinating actually if you just pull
back to a week and a half ago these
stock market indexes were making
all-time new highs the consensus was
this virus is awful but it seems to be
contained the number of cases reported
in China was starting to diminish and
people really felt like the economic
impact would be limited as soon as we
got a spread in Italy in Iran in South
Korea new cases here
that's what investors started to get
really freaked out this week and they
sold because they're not sure of the
extent of it how long it will last and
what the true economic impact will be I
bet you're gonna tell us not to panic oh
but your mom had something to say to you
always does because I said Jill is gonna
come on today and tell us not to panic
yeah still saying what did your mom say
my mother said don't tell people not to
panic it's hard not to panic when you
look at those numbers well okay I agree
with you I think these numbers are scary
because we are now as in a correction
meaning we're down 10 more than 10
percent from the recent highs this is
the fastest correction for the sp500
ever from top to the correction point so
here's why it's scary it happens fast
you get a little bit of like wow I'm I
feel like I'm whiplash but when you
think about it most of us are long-term
investors we are thinking about decades
in the future you probably have a
diversified portfolio meaning your stock
position probably looks pretty rotten
this week but your bonds look great and
hopefully you've got a little cash in
that account when you feel the panic you
try to say to yourself hey wait a second
I don't need this money for a while
on track I don't want to alter my plans
I'm not gonna fall into this trap so
don't make changes you know radically
right now absolutely I'd like to know
when do you panic okay well I think my
panic moments you know and I would I
tell you what if you needed your money
this year if you said I had money in the
stock market and I needed to buy a car I
have to pay a tuition check and by
mistake I had that money at risk then I
think you have to sell now free up that
cash and make sure it's secure but if
you are in know if you don't need this
money this year keep your plan in place
I know it's hard to do again you can
feel the butterflies don't act on them
of course you've got some extra money
laying around you can buy some stuff
look at the market timer right there you
go yeah yeah put that money to work
that's would be very good advice for
sure good advice thank you Joe
Joe thank you very much